So actually, Brennie Brown,
she is a researcher at.
For the university of Texas or something,
but she, um,
she has one of the most famous TED talks on YouTube about empathy.
Um, she says, empathy is a muscle,
and we just have to use it just like any other muscle.
Like you would lift weights and become strong.
Empathy is just a muscle that we have to use.
So I don't think it's that
men are limited in their capacity to empathize.
I think men are limited in their requirement.
What is asked of them to empathize.
We give them so many passes by saying, oh,
he's a man, he's a man,
but he's a human, just like we're human,
and they shouldn't be getting any passes for anything. And.
And just like any other muscle,
if you don't use it,
you lose it. So I think when men or boys are raised to ignore emotion
or to not feel
or whatever weird things,
you know, men have to go through,
I think that's what causes them to grow up emotionally immature.
But they should absolutely still be required to
go through life in the same
requirements as other people.
They should. They should still be able to empathize.